fermé au public depuis leur confinement
cette agence située à montigny le
bretonneux ne peut plus recevoir ses
clients
l'activité est en baisse d'environ 60%
les salariés et agents commerciaux ont
donc mis en place des outils pour
pouvoir continuer à travailler
ça passe par la signature des documents
en électronique par voie électronique ça
passe également par la visite virtuelle
qui était pareil traiter de manière très
occasionnels et est aujourd'hui rendue
systématique
2 par 2 par justement l'absence de ces
rendez-vous physique en effet les
visites virtuelles sont devenu l'unique
moyen pour un acheteur ou un locataire
de voir le bien
le système est constitué d'un trépied et
de la caméra
ça va me permettre de prendre une prise
de vue de la pièce à 360 degrés pour
ensuite l'intégrer dans une application
que j'ai sur mon smartphone le montage
est réalisée ensuite en agence et le
client peut alors circulé dans chacune
des pièces virtuellement dans un bien la
visite virtuelle n'a cette qualité que
d'être une prévisite finalement elle
permet de pré sélectionner justement
d'éviter les déplacements inutiles à des
acquéreurs
bien sûr c'est conditionné par une
revisite en physique dès lors que le
déconfinement pour avoir lieu ces
visites en physique annulés sont une
incompréhension pour la profession qui
demande un assouplissement des règles
je pense qu'il est paradoxal de de
permettre
aux agents immobiliers de réaliser des
états des lieux des rendez-vous
d'estimations et
quand on ne peut pas faire deux visites
dans cette agence
ils sont deux salariés la plupart des
collaborateurs travaillent en tant
qu'agent commerciaux indépendants
seule une personne est en chômage
partiel